Good morning, John.
For Christmas, from her mom,
Katherine received a log book that once contained records from her grandmother's hair salon.
After she had kids, though, she turned it into a recipe book,
pasting in recipes from newspapers and magazines from the  '40s and '50s
They are...interesting, so Katherine and I decided to try a few of 'em out
The results were mixed. Here is our journey.
[music]
Recipe 1 - Golden Rabbit. You make it with two Campbell's soups
Stir WELL.
One can Campbell's Cheddar Cheese soup.
GRADUALLY blend in 1 can Campbell's Tomato soup.
Add 1 quarter cup of milk
Heat
Stirring
Pour over crackers or toast
Mmhmm, Good.
Hank: Bland
Katherine: Yeah, it's not a lot of flavor.
Hank: I have injured myself.
I got too excited about my Golden Rabbit
Doesn't it look like a golden rabbit?
Katherine: This is not on the list of things that I
want to eat again.
Hank: The predominant flavor is crackers
Katherine: Well, I do like crackers.
It grows on you.
Hank: You still hungry? Just add more crackers.
Katherine: Serve it with half a raw potato.
Hank: Recipe number 2 - Popovers
In a bowl, dump one cup unsifted flour, one half teaspoon salt,
2 eggs
(Just break them over the bowl and drop them in so they're staring at you with their big yellow eyes)
1 cup milk.
Beat this with an eggbeater till it's just mixed.
Now fill the cups half-full,
and set the cookie sheet in the 450˚ oven.
You will have 6 splendid popovers
so golden-brown
and exuberantly puffed up that it's almost embarrassing.
I kind of burned them.
Katherine: Yeah
Hank: You know, tastes like bread.
Katherine: Huh, Northern biscuit.
Hank: I'm down with this
Katherine: Yeah
I'd like to try them again.
Hank: Hole in the middle?
Katherine: Hole in the middle
Hank: I don't why it's got a hole in the middle
Ha-owwww!
Hahaha
Recipe number 3 - Beer Dressing
Mix mayonnaise and mustard together, add horseradish and gradually stir in beer.
I mean...it's not good
I don't really like mustard that much though.
Recipe number 4 - Mexican Chop Suey
1/2 pound ground beef fried in butter when possible.
1 cup sliced fresh tomatoes, 1 medium sweet PAPPER
1/2 cup chopped onion, 1/2 cup chopped celery, 1 cup milk, 1 tablespoon flour
Fry the meat slowly over low heat, then remove the meat, leaving the juices,
to which should be added the vegetable ingredients,
Simmer until tender, add tomatoes, after which add milk,
mixed with flour, and simmer again until mixture begins to thicken like gravy.
Then combine with meat and serve immediately
You seem really unexcited about this one.
It said to serve immediately, so we can't dilly-dally
This is probably the best it's ever gonna be
Katherine: It smells like...dog food.
You just went right for it, huh?
(laughs)
Hank: I have a suggestion for improving it.
Huge amounts
Katherine: (laughs)
Hank: -of salt
Katherine: You gonna - yeah - eat more?
Hank: It-it's so much better
Katherine: Right now you're wasting salt
Hank: I maybe over-salted mine
Katherine: Yeah, you really went to town on it.
Hank: Katherine, if you were gonna name this dish,
what would you call it?
Obviously it is inspired both by Chinese food and Mexican food.
Katherine: N-W-what?
N-no, it loo- It's like uhh Cleveland...Chowder
Hank: (laughs)
Recipe number 5 - Orange Cranberry Relish Mold
Dissolve gelatin in boiling water, add orange juice and chill until consistency of unbeaten egg white,
Cut orange in quarters, remove seeds and put through a food chopper.
Add ground orange, cranberry sauce, celery and nuts to gelatin mixture
and turn into a 1-quart mold.
Chill until firm. Unmold to serve.
Katherine: Oooh, nooo (laughs)
Hank: It's...like...a colon!
(laughs) it feels like
Ohhh
It's like coming across, just some sand in your food.
Do not serve your friends or family this.
Katherine: Why does Jell-O even still exist?
Awww - This is what you get if you're - I it's okay! -  in prison,
pri- (laughs) high school, (laughs) o-or the hospital
like, where else does anyone have Jell-O?
Hank: What did we learn about '50s food, Katherine?
Would you rather live today?
Katherine: Oh yeah
Hank: But, I think that there may be, the-there may be some wisdom
Sorry
Katherine: There's a nut in there!
Hank: Helen, thanks.
Katherine: Thank you Helen. That's my grandmother's name,
yes - no-not Helen Hunt.
Hank: Thanks to Helen Hunt, too, though
Thanks, Katherine, for being in a video with me,
Thank you for watching, and John, I'll see you on Tuesday
(music)
Katherine: You gotta lot of cleaning' up to do, babe. Have fun!
I'm gonna go sit on the couch!